en direct dans ce gîte et kader
abderrahim directeur de recherche à
l'institut prospective et sécurité en
europe les auteurs du livre la
géopolitique de l'algérie aux éditions
un bibliomonde bonjour kader abderrahim
merci de répondre à nos questions en
direct sur arte france
une fête nationale spéciale coronavirus
d'un côté la crise sociale de l'autre
dans quel état d'esprit sont les
algériens pour ce 58e anniversaire de
l'indépendance les sentiments mitigés
évidemment c'est une fête de
l'indépendance donc c'est plutôt un jour
de satisfaction et de partage mais on
voit avec l'instrumentalisation du
retour des crânes qu'en réalité le
régime est à la recherche d'une
légitimité qui passe par une histoire
mythifié et il n'est pas dans l'instant
présent
c'est probablement ce qui pourrait
déclencher un nouveau regain à propos du
irak dont la plupart des dirigeants
aujourd'hui appel à une remobilisation
justement c'est la question que vous
vous posez vous m'avez enlever le pain
de la bouche
est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre à des
manifestations aujourd'hui
malgré les libérations ces deux figures
induirait qu'en fin de semaine pour
apaiser les tensions entre la rue
système c'est difficile à dire en tout
cas il y aura probablement des personnes
qui vont descendre dans à l'art dans la
rue pour s'exprimer à la fois parce que
c'est sain juillet qu'il est légitime
bien il ya un sentiment collectif qui
s'exprime de joie et de de partage de
satisfaction mais en même temps il
s'agit également de rappeler que les
revendications née il ya maintenant 16
mois sont intacts et n'ont pas trouvé ni
de d'ouverture d'un commencement d'une
ouverture de discussions ou même de
négociation avec le régime
donc je crois que le vent va repartir
toute la question est de savoir
l'ampleur qu'il pourrait avoir dans les
conditions dans laquelle se trouve
l'algérie aujourd'hui avec un recond
finement partiel comme vous l'avez
souligné un instant est ce qu'on peut
craindre des débordements aujourd'hui
alors que normalement il s'agit d'une
fête
jovial comme vous l'avez dit une fête de
l'indépendance non je pense pas qu'il y
aura de débordement de toute façon il y
en a pas il faut quand même souligner
c'est un mouvement leurs acquis cette
auto appelé selmiya ce qui signifie
pacifique et donc je ne crois pas que
ils vont choisir ce jour symbolique est
important pour tous les algériens pour
déclencher à la fois des confrontations
avec les services de l'ordre avec la
police
et en même temps se manifester dans ce
non je crois pas je pense que si il y a
effectivement des manifestations elles
vont être tout à fait pacifique que
l'ont été les mobilisations qui avaient
lieu tous les vendredis pendant toute
l'année 2019 et le début de l'année 2010
abdelmadjid tebboune le président de
l'algérie exhorte la france a formulé
des excuses envers l'algérie pour son
passé colonial
une déclaration qui intervient alors que
la france est secouée elle même depuis
plusieurs semaines par des
manifestations anti raciste et anti
coloniale quelle réponse à des magies
tebboune peut-il espérer de la part des
manuels mâcon de paris paris qui on le
rappelle un donc restituer des crânes de
résistants algériens vendredi oui c'est
pas la première fois il ya un chef
d'état issu de régine du système qui se
nouent dans dans l'ombre c'est mou va
dans l'ombre demande des études il est
peu probable qu ils les obtiennent et
l'instrumentalisation qui a été fait
lors de retours des crânes à alger
laissa un goût quand même assez
désagréable de voir cette manifestation
de d'instrumentalisation alors qu'il
aurait fallu me semble t'il à la voix
dire des propos et tenir des paroles
apaisantes à la fois à l'égard des
algériens mais également dans la
relation bilatérale entre les deux pays
je tiens à souligner quand même que
c'est la première fois dans l'histoire
des relations bilatérales que les deux
chefs d'états de part et d'autre de la
méditerranée en algérie et puis en
france n'ont pas
connus n'ont pas vécu la guerre
d'algérie et on voit malgré cela parce
qu'on a longtemps pensé qu'il fallait
que cette génération qui le pouvoir ou
s'effacent pour que les choses
s'apaisent et on voit qu'en réalité pas
du tout monsieur est bonne en réalité
reprend la vieille doxa du fln et il
n'est pas non plus ni dans une
perspective d'avenir ni dans une
prospective pour tenter d'établir une
relation nouvelle
rappelons qu'il y à entre 4 millions et
demi et 6 millions et d'ingénieurs et
leurs enfants issus de l'immigration qui
vivent en france et qu'il pourrait être
à la fois utiles aux deux pays pour être
des interfaces vous venez d'évoquer un
des magic tebboune emmanuel macron
justement quelle est leur relation
aujourd'hui on se souvient de la
polémique sur le vrai faux appels
téléphoniques de félicitations de
l'elysée au président algérien après son
élection en décembre dernier oui la
relation elle est ce qu'elle doit être
dans ce genre de contexte et 2 et de
situation probablement cordiale si l'on
en croit les télégrammes diplomatiques
et les dépêches de l'afp
mais pour autant on est à la traîne de
la relation qui avait pu être établi
entre monsieur hollande et le président
bouteflika
peut-être qu'on y viendra on sent une
inflexion sur le plan institutionnel de
l'algérie puisque dans le nouveau projet
de constitution il y à un certain nombre
de comment dire de demande de la france
qui était formulée depuis fort longtemps
notamment une aide militaire de la
france pour combattre le terrorisme au
sahel et c'est un des dogmes qui est
tombé en algérie puisque dorénavant tu
l'une des propositions phares dans la
constitution algérienne c'est que
l'armée en algérie pourra dorénavant se
déployer à l'extérieur de ses frontières
ce kit ou petite révolution culturelle
et qui montre également que ce pays est
capable pour préserver ses intérêts
d'évolution
si kader abderrahim d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
directeur de recherche à l'institut
prospective et sécurité en europe les
pse et auteur également du livre la
géopolitique de l'algérie aux éditions
bibliomonde merci